posting online insults will be
punishable by up to a year in prison
time in Japan starting Thursday when a
new law passed earlier this summer will
go into effect
the law will be re-examined in three
years to determine if it's impacting
freedom of expression you don't say a
concern raised by critics you don't say
that that could happen that was my first
letter you don't say come on no way
proponents said it was necessary to show
to slow cyber bullying in the country
now look at the fines people convicted
of online insults can also be fined up
to 300 000 Yen that's just over 2200
bucks for an online insult previously
the punishment was fewer than 30 days in
prison and up to ten thousand yen 75
bucks they're stepping It Up Japan is
stepping it up big time now check this
out though because I immediately look at
this like any sane person and I'm like
hmm online insults what does that mean
you know my slippery slope here it comes
there aren't clear definitions of what
counts as an insult a criminal lawyer in
Japan told CNN after the law passed the
law says an insult means demeaning
someone without a specific fact about
them as opposed to defamation which it
classifies as demeaning someone while
pointing to a specific fact about them
this is the quote from the lawyer at the
moment even if someone calls the leader
of Japan an idiot
then maybe under the revised law that
could be classified as an insult so if
you call the leader an idiot can you
imagine what I mean in this country
there's a reason I'm doing this story
too so stay seated
look at the bottom the United Kingdom
also has laws criminalizing grossly
offensive grossly offensive public
messages and people have been arrested
and fined for tweets
this is not a joke for tweets the
language and its policies is also
ambiguous and courts decide what counts
as grossly offensive on a case-by-case
basis oh isn't that interesting
so I wonder
if some of this gets politically
motivated along the way and suddenly
that case-by-case basis gets very
selective right think about it think
about slippery slope so the reason I
cover stories like this is you know
people say well it's Japan Jed you know
it's not happening here no not yet
not yet you see it's happening in the UK
and you see what's going on here in this
country you're not blind you're not dumb
you see what's going on here with social
media in this country how on Twitter
people get Shadow banned how they get
banned altogether how certain
misinformation actual misinformation is
allowed to sit while other
misinformation gets pulled down because
you're not part of the cause you're not
promoting the latest will cause whether
it's the covid-19 vaccine and the
messaging they want on that or whether
it's gender and the messaging they want
on that if you don't follow until the
line
you gotta go
you see it happening all the time it's
already happening here so my pleas to
America do not turn into Japan can we
just not allow don't wait till you get
there
don't get there and then say oh how did
we get here
how did we get here
in the same way you don't wait until you
get into a mandate Zone on a vaccine you
stop the truck before it gets there and
you say oh no that's not going to work
for me
okay this is some scary stuff if you
think about it
I also want to be a little controversial
here you Jed someone at home is like no
way not you I'm gonna be a little
controversial when it comes to the word
bullying for a second okay
when I was young and I taught in schools
for a long time so I'm very familiar
with bullying and all this stuff but
when I was young
what was really a problem when it came
to bullying was real bullying and what
that meant was violence
acts of violence toward other kids which
is completely you know should never be
tolerated cannot be tolerated what it
meant was real harassment really strong
language cursing ostracizing someone you
know serious stuff serious stuff where
the parents would get called in you'd
have a conversation with teachers
parents all that stuff
what began to happen I noticed and this
is 10 years ago when I was Dean of I was
an academic Dean in high school what I
started to see was a different pattern
which is people would come to my office
and there would be this huge charge of
bullying and I'd be like okay well
what's going on here and it would be
things like well that you know that
student over there he said that I was
being silly
and I would be like okay
um
and it was being labeled bullying
right so it went from serious acts to
now it was like every time somebody got
a little bit of a feeling hurt here and
there it wound up having to be this big
sit down and this big campaign and
parents get called listen I am not
condoning bad behavior by children right
I often think that when the new when you
see bad behavior by children often that
is a reflection of bad parenting I
always say that your kids you should
teach your kids to be kind and
respectful Above All Else right I firmly
believe that that's something I'm doing
in my home with my child
with that being said
your kid is going to encounter jerk kids
there's going to be kids that didn't
grow up in a home where those things
were stressed there's going to be kids
that are mean there are Mean Girls there
are mean boys they're adult Mean Girls
by the way too and adult mean boys but
they're going to encounter people in
life who are not nice that is a reality
that is a fact you have to also teach
your kids to just puff up in those
moments and just Shake It Off
you have to and again we're not talking
about violence we're not talking about
harassment we're not talking about
serious cases of bullying but somebody
calls you silly or says oh that was so
dumb you're being silly you're being
stupid
Shake It Off build those backbones Young
okay
I'm saying that as someone who sat in
meetings as a teacher when there were
serious cases of bullying that needed to
be addressed and phoned those parents
student advisor academic teen all but I
was in in all of it but I'm also saying
that as someone who would sit there
sometimes and say wow why are we
teaching kids that something like
calling you silly is a moment that we
all need to say no that should be a
moment that that kid said huh whatever
walked away
puffed up walked away and forgot about
it
build your kids to be strong from the
inside out because they're going to
encounter a lot of things in life
they're going to counter a lot of people
who aren't very nice they have to be
able to handle that and it does start
young that's just a reality we don't
have to like all of this but it's true
now let me get to the adults for a
second okay
adults I always talk about the baby
vacation of America and how we're
growing a bunch of adult babies you
gotta stop
you got to stop crying in the corner and
asking for a safe space it's bad enough
that we have safe spaces for kids I
don't have time and no other adult
functioning adult has time to create a
safe space for you so stop it so when I
look at what's happening in Japan
when I look at what's happening all over
the place it worries me because it's a
two-fold problem it's a problem of
wanting to censor it's a problem of
wanting to oh you said something that
goes against the narrative that we want
we have to pull you off and it's also a
problem of people not being able to
handle criticism
and crying who can I cry to can I cry to
the government
will Mommy and Daddy government come
rescue me
stop it
it all needs to stop if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here